honey mama what is it I have to go with
Roy I was told to take a man to hotel I
said that he was an enemy of the state
take off your dress
and in exchange my mother look at the
doctor she made him instead they cut his
throat
there could be no witnesses so they gave
me a choice die or become a sparrow from
this day forward you will become specks
weapons in a global struggle for power
you'll be trained in psychological
manipulation we must learn to push
yourself beyond all limitation take off
your clothes when we are finished with
you the person you were will no longer
exist every human being is a puzzle of
need you must become the missing piece
and they will tell you anything you have
a gift you know how to survive
this is what you were meant to talk
visit Reiter in the government his last
known contact is an American did close I
am a very simple yesterday are we going
to become friends say when you want
it's a sparrow the only matter cuz of
what you can do for them work with me
and make these men pay you are better
this than any of us your only problem is
you have a soul
we can't trust in a word that comes out
of her mouth there's something else
we're not seeing
if she's compromised she will be
eliminated what have you done
you belong to them they won't ever let
go I'll find a way
you